Партнер Владислава, Павло, вже півроку воює в лавах ЗСУ проти Росії.
Спочатку у гарячих точках під Києвом, тепер - на півдні України.
Павло проходив строкову службу в армії, коли почалася війна.
Ніхто не думав, що йому доведеться іти на фронт.
Ми просто думали, що він відслужить строкову службу і повернеться,
і будемо далі жити, працювати, він буде розвиватися у сфері психології,
ЛГБТ-активістом буде і такого плану. А те, що він стане військовим…
Тепер, окрім щоденних переживань за життя свого партнера,
Владислав усвідомлює й крихкий статус їхніх стосунків.
Приміром, у разі поранення Павла, він матиме проблеми з доступом до реанімації.
Адже до поранених пускають лише найближчих родичів.
І хоча чоловіки готові легалізувати свої відносини,
в Україні такої юридичної можливості досі немає.
Ну хіба що, можна буде приїхати, і сказати, що друг і все. Тому що зазвичай пускають,
якщо там буде десь у реанімації, не дай Бог, або щось з ним станеться,
то пускають тільки родичів. Якщо там буде його мама. Мене мама його знає,
і вона може сказати, що його також пустіть, то тільки так.
А якщо я сам приїду, то мене можуть не пустити просто.
Дискусія щодо реєстрації одностатевих стосунків в Україні точиться не перший рік.
Нині у лавах ЗСУ військовий обов'язок на рівні з гетеросексуальними бійцями
виконують також представники ЛБТГ. Однак права у них нерівні.
Якщо ЛГБТ-військовий загине, його партнер не має права на пільги та компенсацію,
стикається з проблемою доступу до тіла та подальшого розпорядження ним.
24-річна Анастасія - головний медик роти. Вона публічно заявила про себе
як про лесбійку, аби привернути увагу до проблем ЛГБТ-військових.
Як тільки почалася війна, так само, як і всі інші, ЛГБТ-представники
також знаходяться тут. Вони роблять ту саму роботу, як і люди традиційної орієнтації.
Ми є, і ми робимо те саме. То чому ми не можемо мати такі самі права, як і всі інші?..
Анастасія у стосунках зі своєю дівчиною вже кілька років.
Однак саме в армії медик відчула особливу потребу зареєструвати їхні стосунки.
З того моменту, як вона приїхала, я задумалася над тим, що я хочу одружитися.
Я хочу якось узаконити наші відносини.
Я розумію, що те, що ми разом, у нашому суспільстві зараз ніяк не сприймається.
І ми хочемо з нею завести дитину. Я дуже хочу дитину. Вона теж.
Ми можемо це зробити, але це документально ніяк не буде затверджено.
Окрім того, що ЛГБТ-партнери не можуть ухвалювати медичні рішення
у разі екстреної ситуації, вони також позбавлені майнових прав,
зокрема на спадок. А також прав на опіку дитини, яку разом виховували.
За словами правозахисника і представника ЛГБТ-спільноти Святослава Шеремета,
повномасштабна війна стала каталізатором дискусії щодо реєстрації одностатевих партнерств.
Коли почалося широкомасштабне вторгнення, це спричинило нові виклики.
Мій колишній бойфренд зараз служить у ЗСУ. Мої друзі там.
Багато наших хлопців і дівчат перебувають на службі у лавах ЗСУ або Нацгвардії.
Це виклики для життя і здоров'я, які мають абсолютний такий несподіваний
спонтанний характер. Може статися будь-що, будь-якої миті.
Питання - яким чином захистити партнерів, які залишилися у цивільному секторі?
У червні на сайті президента з'явилася петиція з вимогою легалізувати одностатеві шлюби.
Необхідні для розгляду главою держави 25 тисяч голосів документ зібрав
всього за місяць, що для України є рекордом.
Володимир Зеленський відреагував. Мовляв, згідно з Конституцією України,
шлюб ґрунтується на вільній згоді жінки і чоловіка. Під час воєнного стану
переписати Конституцію неможливо. Однак альтернатива все ж є
- зареєстроване цивільне партнерство.
Активісти називають цей крок проміжним, адже такий формат
не вирішує питання з правами на дітей, а також переходу на спільне прізвище.
Однак медичні і майнові питання будуть врегульовані.
Якщо ти вже зареєстрований партнер, то ти апріорі за замовчуванням
маєш право приймати екстрені медичні рішення щодо свого партнера
у відповідних ситуаціях… Партнер має однозначно пріоритетне,
що важливо, перед усіма іншими суб'єктами право вживати
чи приймати екстрені медичні рішення.
За словами Шеремета, група неурядових експертів уже розробила
законопроєкт про цивільне партнерство. З надією, що це допоможе владі
пришвидшити процес. Щоправда, за прогнозами правника,
голосування щодо такого закону у Верховній Раді може відбутися
лише влітку наступного року. А доти українські представники ЛГБТ,
зокрема військові, так і будуть позбавлені базових прав щодо партнерства.
Анастасія каже, що в її роті всі знають про її орієнтацію, і цькувань військова не зазнає.
Однак коли мова заходить про шлюб,
жінка наражається на тотальну хвилю несприйняття.
Дуже багато в моєму підрозділі ставляться до моєї орієнтації,
нормально ставляться взагалі до лесбійок.
Але коли я кажу, що хотіла зі своєю дівчиною укласти шлюб,
вони кажуть, що вони не розуміють. Вони не розуміють,
для чого ми взагалі це все виборюємо. А ми реально це виборюємо…
Тому поки що, окрім поля бою на війні проти Росії,
Анастасії доводиться все ще боротися з несприйняттям в українському суспільстві.